Do you remember my personal site from
the beginning of the first lesson?
Well, it looks like there
are some issues with it.
When I opened it up to test on mobile,
in this case, a Nexus 5.
It looks awful.
See how I have to scroll back and
forth to see the whole page?
The page defaulted to desktop
resolutions, which does not look so
awesome on this mobile viewport.
For this quiz,
open up this site with mobile dev tools.
Add a viewport, so
that it doesn't look totally awful.
You will know you've done it correctly
when the page actually fits,
when you try to emulate a mobile device.
Additionally, when you've
set the viewport correctly,
a code will be displayed,
type it in below to continue.